ما سمته روسيا خيانه وطنه بالظهر وصفه
قائد مجموعه بالانتقام من اجل العداله
قائد ان قوته البالغ عددها 25 الفا
مستعدون للموت من اجل الشعب الروسي بحسب
تعبيره لكنه حذر في الوقت نفسه من وقوف اي
شخص بطريقهم لانه سيعتبر حينها تهديدا
وهدفا للتدمير بريغوجين اعلن سيطرته قوته
على جميع المواقع العسكريه والشوارع
المركزيه والمطار في روستوفر روسيه وهدد
بالتوجه نحو موسكو اذا لم ينفذ شويغو
ورئيس اركان القوات المسلحه مطالبه
بالقدوم الى روستوف للقائه رستوف يبلغ عدد
سكانها نحو مليون شخص وتقع على بعد نحو 96
كم من اوكرانيا
و965 كيلومترا جنوب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
بريجوجن باتا معروفا فهو اعلن التمرد
المسلح ضد القياده الروسيه
وبمقدمتها وزير الدفاع سيرفيغو فبحسبه
شويغو هو من اصدر بتنفيذ ضربات صاروخيه
على قواعد ديفاجنر الخلفيه شرقي اوكرانيا
تسببت بمقتل العشرات ما يحدث اليوم لتاج
لتوترات على مدار اشهر بين بريجوجن وكبار
ضباط العسكريين الروس الذين اتهمهم بحرمان
مقاتله من الامدادات العسكريه الحيويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات